the body yeah to the body to the Tak
down to the Mount
yeah watch the
[Music]
wall okay all right so uh what creates
the effectiveness of
this is my back
pedaling
okay but what creates the possibility or
actually the necessity for the
backpedaling is my uh focus on him my
feetness by him so he's coming in and
I'm like here here here and every time
he's catching up because I'm I'm running
backwards and he's going
forward so it's my attachment to him
that sets up the race between running
backwards and running forwards you're
going to lose running backwards and then
he's going to close and he's going to
take you down got it okay so uh the
first thing you're going to do is not uh
run backwards but in order to do that
you can't be attached to him okay so as
he's trying his this thing I'm already
moving and this is going to put you in
that uh spiraling
geometry uh for the iido so that you
want in your iido okay so I'm moving
moving moving okay and you can see I'm a
little
off to his ideal angle he would rather
have me here you see that but I'm over
here got
it so so if I'm straight what happens he
goes here and he goes who he's got me
okay when I curve boom hop and he goes
he doesn't have me you see
okay so when he drives this is when I he
and you get
your noget Wasa Okay so I'm moving
moving
[Music]
go
but if you you are again now just
attached and attached to him it looks
like
this me and now he's got you
again so you can see I'm already gone
when he sets up his weight
shif it's not when I see the kick too
late who gone
[Music]
boom and
then whatever you're stuck
on Boom po I'm not going to try for
something perfect where wherever I
got that's where I'm
at
okay let's try
it okay so in this in this drilling he
he is trying to do his
stuff he's trying to do
it he doesn't have to go full blast he
doesn't have to kill me because we're
drilling you get it but he is trying to
do those moves okay so as as I'm
circling around he's still trying to do
he's still trying to get under and get
that thing you see and I'm I'm
toes what you're naaza is
not it's not a cancellation of that it
is works it works because he's doing
that okay so in other words to me this
is different do you see I went in and
then I throw the
guy he's trying to get me right home
he's trying to get me that energy that's
that's what I I want to deal
with that's what we're
drilling so he goes boom HP pull that
energy so okay what is that what what
you have to do in your
Keyon here there's contestation you see
oh that has to go through me has to go
through me so emotionally I'm relaxed
[Applause]
home it's not
this you see that
difference so he's going to go boom pop
Here Comes his weight right there go
back right when he comes in who this is
where I'm yielding right here fitting in
there loose and relaxed did you feel the
slip it's like a
slip he's going to come in I'm going to
stick to him and no he goes in I slip
right
there slip Bo bend the
yel and that's what I use to
throw
then the throw is CQ
projection so boom H this is
momentum and that's
so he has his
effort what do you notice he's not doing
your perfect somersault
roll who
cares he won't
po that's not it
okay
boom that was it too
[Music]
for
you got to lower the yin
angle your m is too close get off off
your
heels come
on try to go under those
things try to go under
them go under
it
you got to lower it and you got to go
over
it
so remember I'm very critical of
momentum
throws because that's energy you're
coming in you're trying to go under
right your thr still trying to go under
you're trying yes you
see so she's trying to go under this
isn't work cuz she'll counter it go
under it athlete yes do you see you get
it okay so you're not going here like
this got it go in the body right and
then I have to project your energy past
that foot right cuz you where do you
want to step to counter that counter it
counter the momentum throw and attack
with it yes you go watch watch her foot
when she does that counter it
yes
again
projection do do you see what happened
to her foot you see that okay so I'm not
going we're doing our punching I'm not
here and going like this so you counter
it you see the projection do you feel
that okay you guys understand so I've
seen you do enough projection you can do
this but right here you're going like
this F and she's going under
you boom you go under me that feeds the
projection you see it's way you
attack these the
projection not before you attack it's as
you
attack okay all right try it
again snap his head down there you
go you can you can snap it down you can
do a chin strap snap it
down
there you go
good got to you got to you got to keep
the spiral going you don't get to pick
where the projection
happens okay uh ch
Runners there you go
good let him come in good you got to
come in
[Music]
you
see you have to be ready to go the other
way
hey so you you can't remember what I
told you go you can't Pi your way you
can't go here's where I'm going to go so
I'm online you see that so when you go
in I he you
see but some people like you see how you
feel that push on
then so CU you're doing that to some UK
like you're not letting them push into
you push into me this is what I want
you're trying to throw them momentum
okay so when they feel that they come
they come this way you see that and so
you're still stuck going like this
that's how you get caught like that so
let's rewind the
film okay the spiral is going
counterclockwise but now you came the
other way you see so you push and that's
when you have to go this
way okay so that's where you have youri
ten con and your aido ten con that's
where they come in that's where all your
weapons works either has ten con orido t
con okay
so you're
in she comes this way it's that way you
see that okay be ready don't start going
back because then you're in the other
problem got it okay let's
try change direction that's it trist
[Music]
yep
for
that was good
Sky Chase
harders
too much on the line too much on the
line Sky you go back with
[Music]
lace
for
[Music]
hey I'm hesitant to tell you this
because I'd rather you just be
natural okay but there's certain things
certain uh tactical points you don't
want
okay so he cannot get a body lock on me
and I'm going to do po n or Titan it's
not going to happen he cannot let him
get that okay he can get one arm but he
can't get both arms okay so uh is he's
kicking it seemed like the one that I
kept getting was I follow this arm here
you see this arm over here right and so
I'm on the inside of this arm and then
I'm on this this arm over here but he's
going to he's going to uh disconnect you
see and come in if you got it so you you
won't have this arm for too long without
musling okay but the other arm I'm going
to have once I yield to this muscle so
just to be clear he's going to go he's
going to counter that check he's going
to go under you see you guys see that so
if I keep trying to go here my feet are
going to get stuck so that's not how you
handle it you're going to let that go
and you're going to get out of the way
of that hook you see that so that makes
this arm more way more important this
arm you're going to lose this arm okay
unless you muscle then your feet are
going to plant and then he's going to
get you okay so this arm over here is
where I'm adhering he's going to try
underhook and all kinds of stuff does
will not matter okay because he's not
going to be in this position he's going
to be in this position you see that
so I can't let him get both that you're
going to lose this one this one you're
going to have so he goes
p and I'm just throwing on that arm got
it that seemed to be what was coming up
on me and the way that he countered that
arm
okay
um he goes I'll try to do something
different okay boom you're going this
way now okay so all I have is say same
thing you see how you're going to lose
this one on this side so that makes this
one more important got it so how do I
address this one this was in the yield
so in his effort to get it and take me
down I ADH here now with that hip he
goes and I'm over here so you have to
make sure that that arm stays down
because you're going to project this one
over the top so as I watch some of you
you leave it here and you end up
something like that so he's I make him
go under now he brought his hand down
and then I keep his hand down you see I
do it one more
time so I got here I'm going to cap his
elbow but it's down pick your arm
up pick it up that's what I'm doing so
it's down he goes in
p
okay
so if you
are on one side this is basically
K but as a
throw so this shoulder goes down I'm not
trying to throw him over on this one cuz
I don't have the other arm so I throw
this shoulder down
boom on the other one which is like C
Net I have to make sure that this does
not come up cuz this just turns them so
I have to make sure this goes
down down so that this can go over the
top when I project comes in
P you get it you're letting that one up
the yin arm you're letting up and then
you're just turning someone okay all
right pay attention
go
over the top so that that one would have
been the
[Music]
katame there it is right there over the
top that's it you get
[Music]
it there it is again over the top
good
it's got to go lower you have to lower
the
hand come on change directions over the
top over the top over the top no over
the top of the
shoulder over the top of the
shoulder over the top and move get out
of the
way
[Music]
come over the top of that shoulder over
the top you could do it lightly and but
all the way down to the ground you don't
have to kill
her good kite
nice touch your
[Music]
forehead over the top of that shoulder
all the way over all the way over there
it is right
there over the top
nice try to
close
good
over the top down down down down down
there you
go down down down down
down
okay
uh now if you pay attention to his body
it looks because he's being C projected
it looks like oh holy he's chucking
them you know what I mean uh but if you
pay attention to my body and you go
where where's all the
strain you get it okay so uh as I'm
doing this like you're pretty
relaxed if you look at me don't look at
him he looks violent okay so we're
here pretty
relaxed because right now you're kind of
you're you're kind of like uh you you
you are fueling the young young uh um
touch Point way more than it has to be
okay and as you get older or they get
stronger you're going to get less
effective okay so I'm doing the same
thing I'm the free space is very
[Music]
slippery I'm showing you that he he's
not really ever holding on to me
okay
I'm always right this right here right
as he's got his tension every time he
pushes I
[Music]
turn so the throw you're seeing isn't
me that's a lot of shoulder
okay we're in
[Music]
here
he's already going that
[Music]
way what I would like to see is that
slippery part
that's the three
part coming in not here not here and he
goes down he's coming in
slip see let his energy B especially on
the other way so I'm here home he's
going the other way you see here I see a
lot
of
throw he's coming in
slip
spit it then your thres are in
[Music]
there all your strikes in there
everything is you're not being piss in
okay let's
try he's open to a lot of cushy nugget
cuz he cuz you're not coming in and I
task you with coming in for the Tak down
not you're holding your butt out of the
fight there you
go
come over to the top on that shoulder
more bring it towards the ground
shoulder to the ground shoulder to the
ground shoulder to the
ground shoulder the
ground shoulder the ground shoulder the
ground so you're just clenching you're
trying this this is antil
clinch if you stay still and stay in the
line the clinch is going to
work shoulder
[Music]
down
shoulder down
[Music]
shoulder
down shoulder
down keep your hands
up get off the
line
get off the line shoulder down
dude shoulder
down throw the shoulder there you go